[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the lay
hyalpun show i'm super excited for today
it's going to be really interesting um i
am live in miami which is super exciting
um so this is actually powered by the vc
firm icon plus capital um wants to buy
block fi they give amazing interest
rates so definitely check them out i've
left a link um everywhere for you um i
think you can get up to like i think
it's i don't know four percent interest
or something like that which is much
better especially across europe because
you're getting negative interest rates
there um also guys don't forget because
this month um up until october so i'm
giving away a free version of my
audiobook if you do have the paperback
on dressing bitcoin so if you have the
paperback then just let me know and i'm
giving away a free version of my
audiobook all right guys so today let's
kick this off joining me is the founder
of insanely addictive fitness and
previously the director of business
development at ok coin it is alex
feinberg alex how are you i'm doing
great how are you doing
i'm good i'm good it's good to meet you
we're about to you right now i'm in
austin texas i had to uh to move to one
of the two free states in the u.s and so
texas was one of them and oh where were
you before well you know i i spent about
10 years in silicon valley um and you
know maybe just as a background for me
and your audience um
you know after i finished uh playing
professional baseball well maybe as a as
a start you know i want i perceived
freedom my entire life and i as a young
kid i thought that
athletics would be a vehicle for me to
achieve that
and so i um i worked very hard in high
school to
get a college baseball scholarship
played at vanderbilt university got
drafted by the colorado rockies played
two years in their uh organization
before kind of realizing that my career
was coming to the end of the road i
ended up connecting with
one of the boosters for my college
baseball team who gave a quarter million
dollars to the university about 10 years
ago to sponsor a trip to asia for the
baseball team
and um you know he and i got to chatting
i had no idea he ran a hedge fund at the
time
but a lot of people were encouraging me
to get into finance uh because of my
background in sports and my economics
major
and i knew he was a weird dude
but um he was he believed in conspiracy
theories he flew me around on a private
jet when i was 23 years old telling me
about uh you know corruption in the u.s
government he gave up his citizenship in
the early 90s
um and he really hated the federal
reserve
and you know this was before it was
popular to hate the federal reserve he
really really hated the federal reserve
like i remember we went to uh to las
vegas
and uh we were playing blackjack and
he's playing he won like fifteen
thousand dollars in an hour and we go up
to his uh hotel room and he's just
complete just bitching about the federal
reserve and at the time you know this is
before i had like read the creature of
jekyll island even though as a uh
economics major i didn't really
understand the financial system that
well
um but you know after he asked me if i
wanted to work for him i took the
conspiracy theories that he believed in
seriously because he was worth a hundred
million dollars and i wasn't
and one of the conspiracy theories that
he believed that i believe because i
read the federal reserve act was that
the federal reserve uh was and is a
private corporation and so um you know
working at his hedge fund in hong kong
for a year and a half in 2010 to 2011
um sort of made me believe okay this
game is rigged and the manner in which
it's rigged is going to dump liquidity
uh into speculative markets of which
silicon valley is probably the most
speculative market at the time and still
now
and so if i want to position myself
to make the most money i can without
working you know harder than everybody
else
i need to find a way to get back to
silicon valley where i actually grew up
and so i moved back to silicon valley in
um figured out a way elevator pitched
frankly my way into google
um you know using a lot of the you know
psychological frameworks that i learned
as a competitive athlete like
understanding uh different heuristic
models that people use to uh to make
decisions i basically um
use those to my advantage i currently
coach other people to use those to their
advantage if they want um elevator
pitched my way into google uh ended up
taking a sales role worked there for
about six years
um prior to uh then taking the director
of business development position at ok
coin shortly after the crypto market
started rallying in 2017. and so i lived
in san francisco for about 10 years and
then got the f out of there march 14th
2020 when it looked like black friday in
the stores and i was like uh what is
this covid thing i do not want to be in
an urban area
um so i spent last year in idaho where
my mom moved for several months and then
decided at 34 years old i don't want to
live with my mom actually
um and so austin texas ended up being
the spot uh that i moved to uh because
with my current business i thought it
would be uh the most advantageous to
just interact with people who
um want to eat delicious food and get
jacked and uh do it more simply than uh
they think they have to
that is a crazy story i didn't know you
were at google so i'll go into all of
that in a bit but um i'm really
interested to hear these conspiracy
theories which he was telling you so
other than the federal reserve what
other conspiracies was he telling you
and wait how did you meet this guy i
must have missed that yeah so he gave he
was a fan of my my college baseball team
and we always knew he was a weird guy
because just you communicate with him
he's like this guy's a little bit off
but what's weird what's weird like is it
because he's into conspiracies or is he
just no well i didn't know i didn't know
that at the time i first knew he was
weird before i knew he was in the
conspiracy theories i first knew he was
a rich weird guy
um and but i only talked to him a couple
times and then
the fall of 20
2009 sorry the winter 2009 was my last
shortly after my last year of
professional baseball
i uh began to chatting with this guy
because i knew he had businesses in hong
kong and he was rich and i was
interested in foreign currency trading
and
his son friended me on facebook and i
pinged his son said hey i'm interested
in fx trading does your dad know anybody
who might be able you know who might be
interested in chatting with me turns out
his dad trades fx so it's like okay
great i was hoping to use your dad for
an introduction but maybe you can just
re like reconnect me with your dad
um and so you know he believes in a lot
of them um and i wouldn't say that i'm
i've been sold on all of the conspiracy
theories that uh that he believes but um
you know he obviously the the fed being
a private bank uh he thinks it's
controlled by the rothschild family
which
you know if looking at the research at
the time it's it's plausible that it was
uh it's
from the research i did really really
tough to definitively say that that's
the case now but i think he probably
believes that it's the case now
um
you know jfk
a lot of people you know will think that
there's something going on with the cia
and maybe the fed and all that well
that's where the word conspiracy theory
came from anyways right right with uh
with how the the cia you know basically
made it up to disparage people who
challenged them
um he thinks 911 is an inside job
oh wow okay so he's full on uh tin foil
hat and everything yeah um you know
belief on global warming i don't think
he believes in global warming or i i
don't know what he's actually it's
climate change now by the way i'm going
to change it
i don't know what his actual beliefs are
he definitely doesn't have the
mainstream view of climate change but i
don't know if he thinks it's it's
directionally happening just not to the
extent the models uh will definitively
say it is um but he thinks very much for
himself and you know i think what's
important for a lot of people at every
stage of their life is
a lot of the best advice that you get is
going to be uncomfortable advice because
it's actually challenging an assumption
that you have that is wrong
and it's very uncomfortable for people
to remove wrong assumptions because it
makes the world seem scarier than it
really is
but uh you know as a young money
motivated man
uh
i knew he had 100 million dollars and i
didn't and so it was like dude
you're like
this guy has accomplished more than you
uh in all likelihood because he thinks
differently than you
so you should at least do your best to
evaluate what he's saying and make your
own decision on it do not dismiss it
just because it makes you feel
uncomfortable
and so
you know this guy he he's up
200 million dollars on his bitcoin trade
from last year he would just he sent me
his
you know he i think he probably put at
the time maybe half of his net worth
um
you know sold a quarter of it just to
cover his initial uh initial bet and so
with the 75 profit uh of his initial
trade he's up like a lot
and so um
you know you always look at the
scoreboard to determine whether people's
ideas insane ideas are actually insane
and if the scoreboard says they're not
saying then it's actually well no
they're geniuses actually they just see
things differently than you and the
reason why they're rich and you're not
is because they can connect thoughts
that you can't or refuse to
yeah i think you're absolutely right i
think that's where a lot of people tend
to go wrong um in society they often
look at major successful people and and
hear what they have to say and then just
shut them down and say no they're dumb
you know rather than saying hang on what
could i potentially learn from this um
so that's great that's a that's a real
turning point for you in your life um
yeah go on sorry oh i think so and i
think yeah
a lot of people you know when we chat
they're like oh you know you played
professional baseball and then you
worked at a hedge fund and then you
worked at google how you know how did
you do all that
and the reality is um each group is a
social unit it's just people and and so
with within every context it's
competitive humans working in a group to
try to win things
and so once you realize that the way you
know the commonalities between
competitive groups of humans trying to
win things
um
exceeds any differences that they have
so the the uh the event in which they're
competing actually matters less than the
fact that this is a group competition um
that humans are participating in uh and
if you understand the human dynamics you
understand the human psychology that
underpins it all you can actually
fluidly jump from industry to industry
um without actually having having the
industry expertise of people who worked
in it for like five or six years
and so you know had i not
um played baseball at a high level i
would not have forced myself to uh
reassess the world that i lived in and
thought i understood
um
because i wouldn't have seen people who
i had previously designated as less
intelligent than me continued to succeed
in ways that i couldn't and so i think
forcing myself to humble myself enough
to uh reframe and redefine uh what i
believed intelligence to be which i had
to do as a competitive athlete
really made it easy for me to open my
mind to new ideas like federal reserve
conspiracy theories in 2010
or really opened my eyes to new ideas
like understanding how corporate america
works
when i started working at google
and then i think because i took an open
mind to it i was able to
identify different
paths that other people could not
identify
i was you know able to
um
create the fitness and eating programs
that i've that i now monetize um in my
spare time
and it's simply from keeping an open
mind and knowing that you know there's
probably a better way to do it than what
everybody else assumes they're just kind
of too lazy and stubborn to uh to go
through the cognitive discomfort of
continually questioning and reassessing
their assumptions
that cognitive discomfort is um exactly
just what reminds me of the matrix and
everything that's going on in the world
right now and this i titled this show
bitcoin and tyranny um
so i kind of want to talk about there's
so much we can talk about but let's go
into
why bitcoin and why crypto for you
because you know you obviously have this
sports background then a financial
background but why
bitcoin
why do you care about it where does that
bitcoin and fitness come in
yeah so i think i've always been an
independent-minded person i think since
i played baseball uh in college
um i came to view the world as
you know people control other people and
so you know despite the fact that i'm
very anti-marxist and i yeah i see
communism rising in the united states
and i don't like it makes me very
uncomfortable um i could actually
probably generate uh more positive
statements towards marxism and communism
um than 95 of the of americans despite
the fact that i hate it more than 98 of
americans are 99 of americans because so
wait what what positive things would you
say
the the general diagnosis of uh you know
of economic and resource distribution of
marxism is true
the thing that's wrong is the is the
conclusion of okay now what do we do
like in a capitalist society you will
have capital aggregating in the hands of
a small small number of people and these
people will create rules um to make it
more challenging for the smaller people
to accumulate capital and essentially
maintain decent standards of living
that's correct what's incorrect is okay
now the workers of the world need to
rise up and take over the the industries
that were exploiting them
and uh and everything will be jolly it's
like no i think history's proven that
that's not going to happen in that way
and a lot of people are going to die and
end up in gulags but i very much
believed the um the game of exploitation
was there and you know i saw it working
in corporate america um where you know a
lot of times uh you know employees would
believe certain narratives and you just
look at the math and you're like that's
not true what they're telling you is not
true you can look at the earning
statement and know that that's not true
um or you know do you know how little
equity you have in the startup that
you're working in have you asked them
how many shares are outstanding oh no
you haven't okay so your stake is one
over infinity you should assume it's
zero
um and so just seeing people be
exploited um in commercial environments
um and in sports environments uh you
know frankly at certain junctures in my
uh my baseball journey
um
you know really made me put a high price
on my own personal sovereignty um and i
and i understood that in a capitalist
system you know owning assets
gives you freedom it's a very direct
path to freedom and if you can't own the
assets at least you need to own
the uh the source of income that you're
reliant upon because if you don't
they're going to make your life
increasingly difficult quarter after
quarter by placing higher and higher
expectations for the same you know
roughly the same wage and so i very much
didn't want to do that i also uh
understood for many years
that nothing backs the us dollar other
than you know our propensity to fight
wars to make sure that it's used as an
international settlement currency and so
you know despite the fact that i was in
coinbase's office in december 2013
meeting with their director of business
development i think shortly after they
raised money at like 125 million
valuation
um i actually thought the government was
going to make bitcoin illegal because of
what i had yeah i mean i had studied uh
you know different conspiracy theories
around uh you know what we did with uh
gaddafi like the real reason why we took
out gaddafi the real reason why we took
out saddam and i don't know if it's a
singular reason
but i do think the fact that they're
trying to create currencies to
circumvent uh the dollar as a settlement
currency certainly um added to uh why
they were on the bad boy list
and uh and so i thought well yeah like
there's no way the government is going
to let this thing take off
um so i never you know despite the fact
that i was getting bullying delivered to
my office in 2011 2012 at google
literally i was getting like thousands
of dollars of bullying delivered
and there's this coin based company down
the street that was hiring you know bd
reps and i was like yeah but that's not
going to do anything
um
in 2017
when
bitcoin started taking off
and it started getting a little bit of
institutional backing i think goldman
was opening uh planning to open a crypto
trading desk at that point i thought
okay well the people who own our
government seem to
be financially incentivized profit off
of crypto so if those people um have the
regulatory connections that the industry
at large generally lacks
you know i think this thing can take off
and and the fact that there is nothing
backing the dollar
tells me that you know frankly any
currency can be used as a currency so
long as people believe in its validity
and it has some degree of functionality
fungibility you know some of the main
characteristics of a currency um and i
thought well there's no reason why
bitcoin can't potentially be that um if
i'm i think was 31 years old at the time
when i left google and
uh entered the crypto space and i
thought you know the up this industry is
growing very fast there's going to be so
many opportunities here even if i can't
pinpoint one in particular you know i
left google before i had
my job offer lined up because i was so
certain
that uh something good was would happen
you know so i made over 200 000 my last
year at google had worked there for six
years and i just quit without another
offer lined up because i was confident
enough um in my ability to sink in a
ever-changing environment and find my
way and find my path
you know these ideas and these views are
really uncommon i think that's why a lot
of people tend to um just gravitate
towards twitter and meet a lot of
like-minded people so
at google
google
is is known as you know like the big
tech
lefty kind of way of doing things so i
wonder what was it like having these
having these views and then also trying
to navigate a world where you're trying
to find like-minded people who also see
the world the same way as you and also
don't think you're crazy or a conspiracy
theorist like how has that been yeah so
i i noticed at when i was in college you
know i was an economics major took
marketing classes investment classes i
noticed that people who uh wore suits
well
um and were good-looking were always
seen as more credible and so because i i
didn't realize this when i was younger
but
when i when i was younger i would say i
struggled with credibility and not
because the things i said weren't true
in retrospect in retrospect it was
because i thought in ways that nobody
else could understand
and and the things that i would think
and say
uh were a very significant departure of
the of the starting assumptions that the
people i would speak with had
and so they just assumed i was like
making things up and so i noticed when i
was in college like oh
well
people who look good in suits who speak
well seem to be more believable like we
have these people come into our classes
and like literally they could say
anything and i would think that it was
true i knew this i had the
self-awareness
and so a big reason why i stuck with my
diet and my fitness regimen my entire
corporate career was because i knew that
if i was going to have ideas that a lot
of people thought were crazy um it was
my duty to be in very good shape and and
be able to look good in a suit because
all of a sudden you know if you if you
think the same way as a guy who wears a
tin foil hat but you can wear a custom
tailored suit with nice links and speak
you know articulate english all of a
sudden your crazy idea seems like oh
that's interesting i don't i don't
really necessarily know what alex is
saying but he's thought it through
deeply and so that's kind of the
relationship that i had with my
colleagues at google where
um the company you know did change very
much in six years that i was there um
very similar to how uh you know social
systems change social systems tend to
start libertarian and and devolve into
liberalism um you can look at california
california only elected republican
governors for like its first 70 years
like almost exclusively you can go on
wikipedia and look at it you know who
uh represented it or who was in uh san
francisco uh who san francisco mayors
were for the first half of the 20th
century almost all republicans and then
as uh as their model grew to be
functional and larger and more people
came in and they started offering more
social benefits and that types to
attract a different type of person and
the way companies work whether it's uber
or whether it's google companies work
the exact same way the core founding
team tends to be aggressive libertarians
and as they scale they need to start
recruiting people from liberal
universities who think differently and
and tend to be attracted to a stable
paycheck which it will be a very
different type of person than the person
who wants to build something on their
own and so when i joined google in 2011
it was still a libertarian leaning
company
but by the time i had left uh it did
seem like it had you know very
meaningful marxist inclinations but i
will say that with all the lessons that
i learned in my life um playing sports
dealing with the media um you know
working in finance learning how to say
uncomfortable things in a digestible way
kept me sane
because when like i don't know if you
remember when google fired james moore
for writing the diversity memo that he
wrote um you know that memo is based on
the the videos of jordan peterson that
i've been consuming like 20 hours a week
all 2017. and so i knew exactly what the
guy was saying at the time
um but nobody else did
and so when we had our like team powwow
to discuss everybody's feelings after
that uh that memo
started going uh viral within the
company
i was the only person of 15 or 20 on my
team to raise my hand and say i think
that what he said was true
and my team was 50 women and i had
one-on-one discussions with the majority
of them and it wasn't threatening i
wasn't like badgering them i was just
saying like
yeah like this guy is like one of the
smartest people i've ever heard speak
and i really like there's many reasons
that i believe that this is true and
like i looked into a lot of the data and
a lot of the and i could like articulate
the actual studies you know um when you
talk about trait neuroticism
between men and women it's like you can
just go look at the study i remember one
of the researchers names costa the study
includes over 20 000 people and it talks
about the the mean differences in um in
trade neuroticism propensity to negative
emotions between men and women and it's
like
the study says that there's maybe a
quarter standard deviation difference
between the two cohorts across countries
and there's only four countries in the
world where it didn't exist and those
countries are not exactly seen as the
bastions of
women's rights so you know what's your
take on this and they had no response
obviously and they couldn't get mad at
me because they knew i wasn't coming at
them um in an aggressive way i was just
like look we're neither of us know
100.0 percent of what's out there
but this is what i've seen and the best
way that i can interpret this is this
way
what do you think and it was always okay
it was always okay for me to say
um what i believed because of the way
that i said it
yeah i think that's something that
jordan peterson does really well um you
know he wears the suit he um speaks
incredibly well he makes
um small like sorry complicated ideas he
makes them very simple um but my only
thing with him is i'm a huge fan like
absolutely love him but he doesn't fully
get the pass you know like you were
saying if you look nice and you look uh
you know you're not you don't look like
a crazy person with a tinfoil hat people
still
don't
understand him people still don't
understand his ideas
um like
did you see have you seen the famous
kathy newman interview of course i've
seen the cat well yeah kathy newman
intentionally didn't understand his
ideas that was a little bit different i
think kathy newman was smart enough to
understand what he was saying and i
don't think she was although i shouldn't
have put herself in a situation where
she just got so embarrassed and she's
now a meme
oh interesting i i assume that she knew
she was like totally full but oh
absolutely not
no way interesting well you know in this
speaks very much to the arrogance of the
institutional class which i think would
be
a very uh interesting topic
of discussion because it very much
overlaps into uh corporate work and
crypto is you know i i grew up as an
athlete so even though i went to uh you
know top 20 university in the united
states
um i
didn't you know i didn't consider myself
an academic i didn't consider myself an
intellectual it wasn't until i got out
of school i took a gmat realized i
scored higher
than other people who would get admitted
to top business schools
um that i thought oh you know maybe i am
like smart and then i started working
with people who went to ivy league
schools and i started to understand the
way that they thought and and the way
that they thought incorrectly and then
you started to see some sort of
commonality um between their the
incorrect thoughts that they had
um and the incorrect thoughts that
permeated through corporate america
whether they started from mckinsey and
company or started from some internal
think tank at a tech company you start
realizing
that there are common uh ways that these
people misunderstand reality um and
they're they're both ignorant and
arrogant um with respect to uh to to
this reality and so kathy newman i guess
you know from what you're saying it is
very possible that um
you know that she had no idea because
these people don't know that there are
very very meaningful counter-arguments
to what they're saying
yeah absolutely um you're a mute i don't
know definitely not meant to be amazing
okay
stuff going on in the background oh no
no i can't hear anything um yeah no
absolutely i i there's definitely a huge
level of arrogance um but no i look i
look i think you're right i think um one
of the biggest problems especially
during the trump era was um a lot of
trump fans or whatever had a really
difficult time because the media would
constantly pick um people who didn't
come across as well educated they didn't
look very intelligent and so they were
really able to sort of portray um you
know the trump fans or whatever as these
crazy hillbilly type um uneducated
people and obviously that's not entirely
the case if you know the majority of
america voted for him um well i don't
know i don't think to be clear a
majority of america did not vote for him
well he still lost the uh no i meant
previously no no he's still lost in 2016
then the yes but
you know what i mean in terms of just
like how how it works
he was elected as president yeah yeah
that's how propaganda works is you take
a small subsection of your opponent and
and you know in a large country 340
million people
every group has idiots and you just say
well they're all these people and what's
so funny is you know i disagree with my
doubt on a lot of these things because i
uh you know he's probably more communist
sympathizing and i would say i'm more
right at this point or center i don't
know some combination of center right
center left
um
and uh
and you know he said oh you know have
you seen these trump rallies have you
seen this you've seen that i'm like dad
have you looked at the data because all
of the things that you're saying about
republic conservatives that they're uh
you know neurotic um jealous
um you know all of the you know like um
all of the negative stigma that the
mainstream media paints conservatives if
you just google
um you know political differences and
mental disorders and you just like look
at the first few articles that come up
this is google 2021 i don't know how
they're going to change the results in
22 or 23. what comes up
it shows that the same things that they
say are exist in the republican party
are actually statistically more
prevalent in the democratic party
that there's a greater degree of mental
illness
and i think greater degrees of uh of you
know jealousy envy all this stuff uh
that that exists on the left than the
right
so it's like
you know you're you're it's a pot
calling the kettle black like
that's your group that you're saying
yeah no absolutely i think for me
personally i just find that there's so
much division right now and um i feel
like it's only getting worse and
you know i always say they with my vague
they they will continue to make this
division even more intense um you know
with vaccinations and things like that
um but i often look at crypto and
bitcoin as something which hopefully can
bring us together although there's still
further division so
when you
you you were saying you know you decided
to leave this secure job at google um to
go into crypto or just to go and do
whatever else you wanted to do so that
takes a lot of conviction so can you
tell me you know where that conviction
comes from and really just like where
where you see bitcoin's place in the
world given everything we've spoken
about in terms of you know politics and
tyranny
yeah so i think um
you know you in retrospect you could say
it took a lot of conviction it also just
aligned with some frustrations that i
had uh yeah in a regular corporate job
and i had been looking for years for uh
you know i would say faster moving
opportunities
um and you know as i mentioned i was in
the coinbase office in 2013 which i'd
only been at google for like two or
three years at that point two two full
years at that point
um
but it took me six years to leave
because i was very picky about uh the
different bets i would take i knew that
a lot of people who left for startup
roles got worse jobs than they left at
google had to work harder for less money
and very limited equity upside and i
wasn't interested in doing that and so
when i saw this big wave and everything
rallying in the altcoin market in late
um yeah i mean i thought it was
overbought i didn't think it would crash
by 90 but i thought it would crash by 50
or something like that
um and so to me it was just like there
are a ton of smart people in this space
uh there's a ton of capital in this
space if you have if you combine those
two things a lot of good things happen
so this is a very non-academic
assessment like i wouldn't be able to
write this assessment in the mckinsey
report um and uh you know if i worked at
mckinsey and have my boss say that's
okay it's like you only need to know two
things there's a lot of smart people and
there's a lot of money
and so generally speaking when those two
things intersect a lot of good things
happen it doesn't you don't need to
create mathematical models around it you
don't need to do case studies around it
you don't need to do typical consulting
work or typical analytical work that
would be expected of you in a corporate
job you just know that something good is
going to happen
and so that was sort of the extent of
the thought process that i've had and
frankly with the best decisions i've
made in my life
they've been made with um
uh
i guess very simplistic motivations like
to that extent
and and if i think about the you know
the few best decisions i've made in my
life none of them have taken more
thought process than that despite the
fact that a lot of the other things i do
in my life um do you take a lot of
thought process
and we were speaking earlier you
mentioned that there was certain kind of
propaganda going on at google i'd love
to understand more about this yeah so i
actually write about this um in my cheat
codes for surviving corporate america um
you know for those of you who've who
just started following me on twitter
maybe just coming across me today
i initially got my start um on the
fitness side which i'm sure leona we'll
get to later um well i can cover it now
android
entering the crypto space in a sales
role um with a very small twitter
account in 2018 i told myself because
industries are constantly changing i
told myself that if i don't have 10 000
followers on my twitter account
um within two or three years i will not
be employable in this capacity in the
crypto space because i think anybody
who's paying me at that level will
expect that i have some degree of
distribution
uh greater than just my rolodex so i'm
going to need to build a crypto account
and um you know what i had realized from
my uh
hobbies which included lifting weights
and eating delicious food over the prior
five years is i noticed that i was able
to to get results
that were a lot easier
um than what most people got with
mainstream fitness i never counted
calories i never went through a you know
calorie cut i didn't i was training less
and less and eating more and more
enjoyable food and i thought oh there's
over 100 million americans who are
diabetic or pre-diabetic or obese so if
they knew it could be as easy as i've
found out it could be um this is
probably one of the best ways i can
impact the world so i'm gonna create a
crypto or a twitter account around this
content specifically
and then once i can get to grow it to
five or ten thousand people then i can
start talking about more crypto stuff
because at the time i didn't really have
a very unique um perspective on crypto
and so
um that was sort of how how my twitter
account um came up
and i forget exactly why i mentioned
that but specific to your question on
propaganda at google
um i'm i i'm constantly playing
cognitive games within my own mind to
reframe issues objectively because what
i've noticed uh as an adolescent and
young adult
and now getting into middle-aged adult
is that any time somebody's trying to
spin something on you
um they will take something that's
mathematically one way and they will
present it as if it's not like that and
so a lot of times uh the way
institutionalists will do it is by
pretending that the ideas that they have
that are subjective are objective in a
way that a large company can do that is
they say well the promotional process
works like this
it's like okay that's a negotiation
right that's not that that is your side
coming to the table and say this is how
this is the rate uh that we're willing
to raise your uh raise your salary at um
and and we are not willing to raise it
uh in
excess of x
um across y period of time so i view
this as a negotiation i don't view this
as a rule it's something objective it's
like no this is what they they came up
with to maximize their own profits and i
disagree with it whereas a lot of very
nice kind corporate employees
uh friendly colleagues of mine like
literally could not see outside the box
that the compensation structure in the
promotional structure uh was designed to
maximize the extraction of value on
behalf of the shareholders of you
and and you are being set up and and
this is the case of employees at every
publicly traded company is you're a
major uh line item that the cfo needs to
account for needs to figure out how to
not let that line item grow dramatically
and so that's why they hire hr teams to
uh then hire compensation consultants to
figure out what is the easiest way they
can uh not pay you more for as long as
possible without having you leave
and so like if all you do is see things
okay what is this person's job why does
the the svp of hr report to the cfo and
not the chief revenue officer oh because
they're responsible for costs not
production or more costs than production
okay
so if they're responsible for managing
costs and they create these rules what
do you think these rules are for
um and so just just understanding the
world quantitatively and mathematically
um is i would say a necessary
precondition to seeing the world
objectively um because you can keep
track of things and you can keep score
and so when you know that uh you know
the score the scoreboard continually
favors one side over the other
you know then it's very possible that
the people who are constructing the
rules of the game did it in a way to
affect that outcome
um and that's kind of like how corporate
propaganda works
and so you said so when we were speaking
you you were saying that you're seeing
these similarities um with the biden
administration so explain that to me so
when i see jen paske if i'm saying her
last name speak uh she to me speaks
exactly
exactly her mannerisms uh her tone her
cadence
exactly
like a full of consultant i don't
know what her background is i assume she
worked at mckenzie or something like
that
wait
who are you talking about again the
white house press secretary oh yes yes
yes yeah yeah i don't know what her
background is but she communicates her
communication style is exactly the same
well i it probably works for a lot of
people like that's a fairly elevated
position and i'm sure was very
competitive that a lot of sociopaths
were gunning for
um
and
you know of all of the people they could
have picked they picked her so she
probably does bring something to the
table that a majority of people cannot
um but what that means is she's able to
communicate in a way that a lot of
people probably like you know i get
these push notifications because apple
signed me up for them for like
huffington post and so on
you need to delete that rather i do i do
but um
just i just want to say actually just on
that point though i used to have notes i
used to have news notifications i turned
them off i deleted it literally as
covert started last year oh it's
probably smart yeah i don't know they're
like auto set up i get like fox news and
huffington post which is like great but
to get rid of it polar sources and so
you know i don't know some
a couple people like ten a thousand a
million like some degree of people like
her um but when i see her talk
um she speaks exactly like uh you know
some sort of corporate vp or
mckinsey consultant who has nothing of
substance to say and her main job is to
spin things or obviously it's the real
intention of initiatives um so that's
exactly what i see with her
um and and more broadly like
uh whichever political party is in power
tends to be the one that's
extremely full of
and
you know right now that happens to be
the democratic party
yeah i've seen some um i actually didn't
know her name um not being american so
um but i i've seen a lot of different
clips of hers recently um and there's a
lot of um avoiding
answering questions i mean that's the
that's just really the biden
administration in general um the whole
um
the whole i can't remember what bill
they're doing but they were sort of
saying that it's going to cost zero
right
yeah oh okay sure but this is what
happens when you have true believers and
um you know the the deeper i get into
understanding the world around me it
forces me to understand human psychology
and you know as i mentioned i always
argue with my dad about politics uh
unfortunately like it's we talk on a
regular basis and we constantly disagree
on politics
and you know one thing that um i think
about the way he thinks and i think
about some of the deficits in his own um
cognition
is uh he's very good at analytical
thinking except he has some blind spots
that rely on assumptions that aren't
true uh like a few amount of false
assumptions
may mean that the conclusions that he
arrives at are completely far off um and
so you know what that means around like
his support of government well he's a
little bit of an anxious person himself
he's also not religious 200 years ago a
person like that would have been kind of
steered towards some religious community
and said well your anxiety is you know
due to your lack of relationship with
god and so the way you fix that is you
know you do this and that the other
thing
and um you know because he's a
graduate school educated individual uh
who's a lawyer
in the 21st century
you know he thinks he's a little bit
beyond that and so he's opted for the
the church of rationality um which has
led into the church of the democratic
party
um
whom he now sees in some regard as the
you know
that party takes this the his brains
it fills his brain's void um
that needs a savior
right and so when people people's brains
have a void for a savior and that savior
in some people's brains is uh their
concept of a deity and that savior in
other people's brains is the government
and so a lot of people just believe that
the government is going to take care of
them the same way other people
whom the government believers think are
ignorant believes a man in the sky is
going to take care of their needs
the issue i think is when one of those
beliefs leads to the implementation of
authoritarian policies um you know
because a small percentage of the
population is too neurotic to deal with
the realities of life and that it is
dangerous and we cannot plan around
everything and safeguard against
everything possible
i think you touched on a really
interesting point which is something i
keep hearing recently it's how people
have these conversations with their
parents they have good relationships
with their parents their parents um they
hold to high regards you know they say
they're very intelligent they're they're
a doctor or you know they've always sort
of seen the world in in the correct way
but when it comes to recent events our
parents just aren't quite on board
aren't quite seeing it the way that we
see it they have these blind spots as
you say and i'm not 100 sure why that is
but i do have a theory in that we're
just of a different generation so
we
our generation now has access to
technology so we which means we have
access to more ideas so for example
jordan peterson right he has completely
changed my entire um perception on
everything everything um like feminism
is a fantastic example i'm not gonna get
into it um but he's completely changed
my perspective on it and um
that is something which
i don't believe you know my parents
would have had access to
um you know growing up in the 70s i
don't know when they grew up something
like that um so
it it is really interesting um
is this something that you've come
across you you see more you know
parents are there but not fully there
100 and to build on that and you know
offer my own perspective as to why
that's the case i think you know as we
get older our bodies and our minds
become more immobile because we
become lazy enough to only be able to do
the things that we demand of it on a
daily basis
and so one thing that your brain does
in your 20s and your 30s probably your
40s
is it starts to recognize um trustworthy
sources versus untrustworthy worthy
sources and in our parents generation
the pattern recognition that they that
they relied upon in their 20s 30s and
40s was oh the new york times is
trustworthy oh the cnn delivers good
news and it's the national enquirer that
delivers the fake stuff but the real
stuff um comes from these publications
that are under this brand name that are
written in this font and so that's the
shortcut i can use to know whether it's
credible what's the source
and so um that neglects
the fact that
the same institutions that carry the
same name that write in the same font
um
that uh you know
have the reputations that they probably
earned and deserved at one point in
their uh in their organizational
lifespan
um
now they can just make things up because
the employees within those organizations
are very different than the employees
within those same organizations 30 or 40
years ago those people are not
trustworthy now
um
and and so
older people who haven't like they're
not con they're you know they basically
finish their pattern recognition that is
uh is coloring how and why they think
they are not able to adapt to the fact
that these institutions may once have
been trustworthy but now is not that
time and so they they do not see the
value of um finding alternative
information sources um
you know and then and so if you only
trust the mainstream narrative you know
you're effectively in a cult and you
don't realize it um because that cult is
telling you all the ideas of the
outsiders are wrong and dangerous and
scary and they're going to lead to white
nationalism and all these things
and it's like dude have you gone outside
does what you're seeing on tv align at
all with what you see in the real world
um or you like data here these are
government statistics
that are not even being referenced in
the articles that you're talking about
um if that was a genuine concern of the
author and the and the most reliable
statistics directly refute the point
that the art the author's making um
stats can be wrong but it's incumbent
upon the author to at least reference
the fact that the stats do contradict
him or her and and offer a reason for
why those statistics are wrong but they
don't they just pretend that those stats
don't exist which is how you know that
they're not being genuine in their
intent
yeah i think that right now we are going
through a really interesting shift and
um just to bring this conversation back
to crypto i do think that we it's sort
of that safe haven for these ideas and
this free thinking this alternative way
of seeing the world and so i do i do
hope
you know i i think somebody's written in
the comments they're talking about like
a civil war coming and people often talk
about like florida and texas breaking
away from america and all this stuff but
i do think that something is coming in
in some ways i don't necessarily mind
because i think that we need this crazy
um
reality check you know whether it's like
forced vaccines whether it's covert
restrictions for the fourth year or the
third year whatever it is now um i do
think that we we do need something to to
really wake people up i don't know we'll
have to see what happens but well i
wrote an article a year ago
before trump got kicked off of twitter
uh that said
and before bitcoin i think even crossed
20k definitely not yeah
and i wrote you know bitcoin the
currency of the canceled so you guys can
probably google that title and it would
come up under my medium page
and uh
and so i kind of thought like as more
people get cancelled um and get kicked
off of mainstream financial platforms
exactly um they're going to end up using
bitcoin and so what i actually see
happening with the political
disagreements that are occurring in the
u.s is there's a recurring need for the
people on the left to inflate and that
includes the fbi um to inflate the
threat of white supremacy and and
there's a few key in like toxic
masculinity there's a few key issues
where you're like
what these guys like it doesn't matter
what's going on they just really really
want to make sure that you're scared of
this thing whether it's russia white
supremacy
yeah
and so it's like okay clearly they have
an agenda to make sure that you're
scared of this thing
um clearly there's some sort of uh
agenda
to force medical decisions on other
people
and they're trying to make the two
things intersect in people's minds like
any good propagandist would
and so you know what do i think the next
uh
you know the next domino to fall could
be
uh you also know the left is trying to
ban guns um and yeah if you'll notice in
the in the us relative to other
countries that have banned guns the us
doesn't have lockdowns that are quite as
severe as many of the countries that
have banned guns although there's not
guns in scandinavia and but that's a
little bit of a different thing that's
going on there and um
and so what i see happening is
you know for simple descent you know
when you say well toxic masculinity is a
problem toxic masculinity is actually a
space holder for dissent
and so uh instead of saying well we
don't want to
dissent is dangerous they can't say that
just yet
um so they say well who are going to be
the most likely loudest dissenters men
okay so let's just stigmatize toxic
masculinity um so we don't have to
directly stigmatize dissent we can just
uh stigmatize the people who are most
likely to dissent yes and so what's
what's going to end up happening because
it's a large country is if they end up
taking more aggressive
measures to force medical decisions on
other people uh or limit their ability
to uh make an income if they don't
submit to medical decisions being made
for them
uh you know one person of a hundred
million is going to do something stupid
because that's what happens when you
have freedom and 100 million people is
someone's going to do something dumb
and so you know if that person ends up
uh you know
shooting up some people uh which would
be unfortunate obviously um but not
unlikely in a country that has 340
million people like one person is going
to go crazy every day you can guarantee
yourself that
um they're going to use that as a excuse
to like shut down uh dissent of the left
and so imagine what would happen if one
day
you know
uh there was some sort of uh uh you know
mo i mean look at how they're responding
to january 6 they're massively inflating
a non-insurrection for being an
insurrection so obviously if there's any
sort of uh domestic pushback that
includes anything violent they're going
to blow that so far out of proportions
uh that is in the government and then
what's going to happen is because the
government's blown it out of proportions
the institutionalists who populate these
big tech companies are then going to say
oh yeah well the government made this
declaration therefore we need to do the
responsible thing and not just kick off
the the people who are directly involved
from the platforms but kick off anybody
who's like within two degrees of them
from platforms because we need to kill
this cancer before it spreads okay so
what would that mean for somebody like
you or somebody like me you know even
though you know we will denounce
violence and not be anywhere close to
participating in something like that uh
because we may have like commented on
the same tweet as this as the person uh
we get put on some list uh we get kicked
off these platforms we get our paypal
accounts banned and then all and then
you know possibly you know there's some
financial account restriction too that
could happen and none of these things
seem plausible now but you realize that
once one thing happens the overton
window shifts and new things become
conceivable that were previously
inconceivable and that is how i think
bitcoin could end up becoming an
alternative currency for the canceled
yeah i mean
that always reminds me um of piers
morgan because he
did an interview with ben shapiro and
ben shapiro was explaining the need for
guns
and ben shapiro was basically saying um
if you don't believe that your
government could become tyrannical and
therefore you need a gun to protect you
and your family then you're naive and
you know you can sort of look at that
and say um at the time oh he's just
being a conspiracy theorist he's being
you know overly concerned but when you
look at the state of the world and
what's happened over the last 18 months
nearly two years um anything is possible
now so um i wouldn't yeah so i wouldn't
rule anything out um but alex what tell
me what you're working on right now and
where can people um find you and you
know you said you've written some
articles so how can people follow all of
this work yeah i think the easiest way
is to follow me on twitter my handle's
alex feinberg one um you know what i've
worked on last year is delicious recipes
that a lot of people eat without really
you know taking care of portion sizes
and they find their bodies are feeling
better their workouts are better and
their bodies are looking better
i also have an eating framework that
shows how i you know come to have four
or five percent body fat at 35 years old
without ever counting calories along
with the training plan that enables it
that's a lot easier than what most
people do
so all of those are i talk about those
on my twitter handle all the time and
then more recently uh as i mentioned
i've done more um corporate navigation
work so um
uh you know in the process of me working
in in the crypto exchange that i work
for from 2018 to 21 uh 2021 also grew
this nice twitter handle um and now a
lot more people who are following me uh
realize that a lot of the shortcuts that
i'm seeing in fitness and eating um you
know the same brain that created those
or discovered those also has found a lot
of corporate shortcuts too uh so i've
released uh the guide to uh the cheat
codes to survive in corporate america um
also today i released uh the aristocrats
guide to salary negotiation that a lot
of people um get wrong for uh for very
understandable but easily addressable
reasons and so um just put that out i'll
continue to push it we've had several
people purchase it already today um and
i think that's gonna help a lot of
people out because uh you know i've
recently started working with other
people um one-on-one some on salary
negotiation and we've gotten them like
you know 30k raises in like two months
so um you know that's how you can engage
with me i keep my dms open i will
continue to keep them open until
probably it gets too crazy yeah but i'll
probably at least until a hundred
thousand followers will keep them open
ah nah i keep them open i've got over
that and i keep them open that's totally
fine well i'll reassess it at that point
yeah it's good fun it's all funny games
um but alex i want to thank you so much
it's been so interesting hearing your
perspective guys follow alex he has some
really delicious recipes um i'm always
looking at them i'm just like wow and of
course some really unique perspectives
on well come on austin austin you can
actually like eat some i know i i might
do since i'm in miami i might do i do
want to go to texas next yeah i might do
it
all right you got to invite to chef
alex's kitchen when you come
all right it's officially considered all
right guys thank you thank you so much
for watching and alex thank you so much
for coming on thanks this is great
all right see you next week bye
[Applause]
[Music]